as a fat person
I struggle with overconsumption
I’m talking about shopping
I have such a love for clothing and fashion
but because I'm a larger fat person
it's really difficult to find clothing that I like in my size
growing up there is almost never clothing that I wanted to wear in my size
so in the last few years
we've made progress in plus size clothing
so when I find clothes now that I like and like
they're making things that I wanna wear
I immediately jump on it and I buy it
because being fat
sometimes just clothing items that I've never seen
and never thought will be made in my size
and I don't know if like
it's gonna last
if it's gonna be sold out
if they're gonna make it again
but the problem with that is
sometimes I end up buying things that I don't end up wearing and like
I have no use for
but I'm like
I wanna buy it just like
in case I need it
and I really wish that I could be more intentional with the way that I shop
but we've literally seen in the last few months
how plus size clothing is being kind of walked back
like stores that were like oh hey
I'm size inclusive are now like
just kidding and like
we're seeing in real time
like my fear
the one that I was having is valid
and it's like
how do I combat that over consumption
when I know there genuinely is a real possibility that item might literally
never exist ever again
and also so I'm the type of person where like
I'll find something that I really like
and I'll just wear it consistently
like at least once a week
you know what I mean
like very very often
I'm like a cartoon character
like I have like my you know
my set outfits right
but the clothes are also not made well
like plus size
people often don't really get good quality
like options
you know so there's
like of course
they're gonna run through quickly
especially if you're wearing them often
and so now I'm in a position where like
if I have something that I like and I like
get the use out of it
and I wear it it
it'll be like
unwearable in a few years
and I don't even have the option to pay more
to get a better quality garment that will last
like a lifetime
so I have literally no choice
I'm sitting here like
debating rebuying this like
black velvet dress that I like
that I wear all the time
but the straps are already
like peeling off
and I might like
I'm gonna sew it just like
to get more use out of the dress but like
uh it's so frustrating
like literally
either my choices are like
buy three of the same dress that you like so you know
you will have it
or just like
wear it till it falls apart
because it's gonna fall apart
because they don't make quality clothes for plus size people
oh my god ugh
anyway and I'm an anti capitalist like I
I inherently do not support over consumption
but I am an over consumer when it comes to fashion and
like shopping
because of this exact reason
and I'm not gonna get into how expensive this is
like it is a privilege to be able to rebuy the clothes that I want
but like it's just
it's not fair
it's not fair that we have to do that
like these like
fast fashion
cheap clothes are not a problem just for fat people
it's a problem for everyone
but thin people can at least go to like
a thrift store and get old
vintage like
quality made clothes
but like obviously I
as fat person
cannot do that
so I'm literally at a thrift store
I am sitting in a parking lot
at the store
making this rant
because I'm so
I'm so like upset about this whole situation so I don't
this is also why plus size people get mad at thin people
who take plus size clothing from thrift stores
because like
obviously it's a thrift store
first come first or whatever
do what you want
but also there's so little of it
that actual plus size people can't shop at thrift store sucks
I literally sent my sister in
and I'm like
I'm gonna go in at the end to look at the jewelry and like
the three pieces that are in my size
because obviously
obviously there's no vintage
plus size clothing so anyways